salut tu peux voir un truc de ouf je te
dis pas mon père la tête qui fait on
jamais rien vu pareil
sriux plus hab de la région oncir
crépè on cherche quelque chose
d'inabituel et de
dangereux mais tu quoi toi
il m'arrive un truc je vois même pas
comment te l'expliquer jette un il il
adore se cachet là
dedans il est cool et hyper doué il sert
de moteur à mon 44 c'est bien
çait tu l'as appeléit tu crois que tu
peux me
battre tu as vu ça
CR tu te demandes pas d'où il vient je
vais te ramener chez toi loin de ceux
qui te
cherchent moi aussi je
t'aime fais gaffe tu préfères pas
prendre le volant laisse-moi faire je
vois mieux la route que toi pas par là
j'ai touché son œil triip ces messieurs
veulent te parler j'ai pas envie de vous
suivre bah tu m'as
forcé le monstre est dans la
voiture waouh tu as vu on peu on a
vraiment fait ça carrément ouais je suis
chercheur et je veux vous aider c'est
une famille il te faut quoi des
44 j'espère que tu as pris des leçons en
me regardant tu roulais encore à vélo il
y a pas 8
jours oh pourvu qu'ils ai mis leur
ceinture allez go
ok creit à table j'adore ta caisse merci
ah
[Musique]